In the desert of southern Israel,...
...a team of six scientists have begun simulating what it might be like to live on Mars.
The red-hued Ramon Crater will be home for about a month...
...to the five men and one woman participating in the mission.
Their AMADEE-20 habitat is tucked beneath a rocky steppe.
Inside, they sleep, eat and conduct experiments.
Outside, they wear mock spacesuits fitted with cameras, microphones...
...and self-contained breathing systems.
Outside, other engineers and specialists will work with a drone and rover...
...to improve autonomous navigation and mapping on a world where GPS is not available.
Altogether, they will carry out more than 20 experiments...
...in fields including geology, biology and medicine...
...and hope to publish some of the results when finished.